morning hex Sunday 100 questions four
minutes go
how many puffs with puff puff puff puff
puff 6 what kind of dog is Willie the
barky kind how will the world end
whimper not bang favorite picture book
little pee in your pants do you like
your bubble head Nikon or Canon Canon
favorite Disney movie Fantasia
did you ever get a cat the yetis
allergic favorite your high school
senior will Paper Towns be published in
France jabal school we are you a ninja P
oh oh no cheese height tick one who they
have is Hank he's a massive incandescent
gas hog you have a puff longtime
favorite Hank song anglerfish can I hug
you
now right now I'm answering questions
why because it said so new Star Wars
trilogy rolled trilogy come on Big Macs
and whoppers fitness challenges where is
the puppy gillich apples river band the
mountain goats second favorite band
still the mountain goats third favorite
band Hank Voight favorite band then back
to the mountain goats favorite shirt
paper or plastic tote bags favorite
scent white musk did you like the Hunger
Games
yes Argyle double yes what's next
favorite city Amsterdam first job Steak
and Shake Ikea bookshelves Star Wars or
Star Trek will you write a sequel to
Looking for Alaska vomit on did you like
Kenyon wait when April Joyce or Yeats
Joyce miss video editing software final
cut and grandma living plus two twelve
plus one riddle pwned liquor Mario Mario
what's the meaning of life other people
why you sweat so much it's hot favorite
time period now are you worried about
balding geez I wasn't till you mentioned
it but now I am can you speak Klingon
look like Oh poop ie Alaska wins you're
Margo martyr unstoppable force or
removable object force who monkeys what
monkeys where in your pants when now why
I don't know you got some bananas in
there or something
what's a question it's like a statement
only things like this founder Whitman
Whitman reach your boxers boxers
favorite arcade game nerdfighters you
wish you had a different name there's a
guy in the US Marines whose real name is
Lance Corporal max bike master I
wouldn't mind being Lance Corporal max
fight master worst President Buchanan
ketchup or mustard no no no no
that job after you're not that good at
the main-course Sox were Yankees Cubs
favorite type of pie the mathematical
constant type what you never word
together the accidental and uranium your
burgers and fries annoying distraction
or pleasant surprise
pleasant surprise favorite play Hamlet
Where's Waldo by the cotton candy what's
up not much I'm just trying to atone
your questions in four minutes favorite
teacher first grade miss Newton one
thing you can't live without water who
loves you baby my mom favorite Beatle
John favorite color green see see what I
did there no they are man a man a so
near far sighted near how's the weather
do you like pizza mi tu nerdy do you
like your iPhone worst impulse-buy sunny
yes no yes and this shirt pyre cake bake
who's your hero this guy
glasses prescription about that favorite
veggie num num num picard kirk picard
muffins
yes nirvana sure hope or despair hope am
i cool your jokes Colin or chew chew
lefty righty do you love me yes are you
happy almost this is the last question
no is this the last question yes I'll
see you on Tuesday
Oh
hi I'm a hot mess